[Musik]
ein maskenhafte nach dem anderen erst
csu politiker georg nüßlein über 660.000
euro für die vermittlung von masken
einfach in die eigene tasche und dann
nikolas löbel cdu politiker eine viertel
millionen euro einfach abkassiert die
bürger sind fassungslos und sehen
gleichzeitig dass beim testen und impfen
einfach gar nichts funktioniert was
bedeutet das alles für das vertrauen in
die politik welche konsequenzen gibt es
für diese masken raffkes und wann hört
das kolossale scheitern in der korona
politik endlich auf ja und darüber
möchte ich sprechen mit meinen gästen
dem cdu-generalsekretär vc jörg dehm
spd-generalsekretär lars klingbeil dem
fdp- generalsekretär volker wissing und
dem grünen bundesgeschäftsführer michael
kellner herzlich willkommen schönen
guten abend herr zwegat mit ihnen möchte
ich direkt einsteigen denn die
nachrichten die deutschland beschäftigen
sind die nachrichten aus der union so
schlecht waren sie in den vergangenen
jahren in den vergangenen jahrzehnten
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr schämen sie
sich eigentlich mittlerweile teilt
dieser raffte fraktion zu sein
wir sind jetzt alle nicht nur verärgert
wir sind wütend auf das was jetzt ans
tageslicht gekommen ist es sind zwei
abgeordnete die hier die hand
aufgehalten haben und sie benutzen das
ansehen aller abgeordneten alle
abgeordneten der union überhaupt des
parlaments denn in dieser schweren krise
haben so viele abgeordnete hart
gearbeitet geholfen auch wenn es um
schutzgüter ging die haben gesagt da
könnte man etwas bekommen die hinweise
weiter gegeben aber nie die hand
aufgehalten
das gehört sich nicht und deswegen sind
wir mehr als empört sie mir gesagt mehr
als empört und bevor wir weiterreden
über die masken raffkes möchte ich ihnen
einmal zeigen wie sehr die korona
politik und die debatte um die
korruption bereits das vertrauen in die
politik angegriffen möglicherweise
teilweise zerstört hat
ein ganzes jahr krise nun hat sie auch
die regierung selbst erfasst
unzufriedenheit wut vertrauensverlust
der politik droht die knallharte corona
abrechnung und dabei fing alles gut an
für die krisenmanager 65 prozent der
deutschen standen selbst im harten
lockten im vergangenen frühjahr voll
hinter ihrer regierung
doch seit november kippt die stimmung
monat für monat zu wenig impfstoff
deutschland von vielen anderen staaten
abgehängt und die politik übt sich im
schönreden glaubt dass im großen ganzen
nichts schief gelaufen immer mehr
deutsche sehen das ganz anders
die unzufriedenheit mit der korona
regierung nimmt weiter zu anfang februar
sind erstmals mehr deutsche mit der
politik unzufrieden als zufrieden
kein wunder der gesundheitsminister kann
auch sein schnelltests versprechen nicht
halten stattdessen machen sich
unionspolitiker in der krise die taschen
der korona sumpf der csu abgeordnete
georg nüßlein er soll abkassiert haben
mit einem fetten masken deal bis zu 600
60.000 euro die staatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt gegen ihn
ein einzelfall nein denn auch der
cdu-bundestagsabgeordnete nikolas löbel
dachte in der krise zuerst an sich hier
bilder von ihm mit jens spahn aus dem
letzten bundestagswahlkampf
während der gesundheitsminister im
vergangenen frühjahr daran scheiterte
den deutschen rechtzeitig masken zu
beschaffen
göbel zeitgleich deutschen unternehmen
an sie mit solchen schutzmasken zu
versorgen mit solchen e mails und dann
kassierte löbel ab 12 cent pro maske
machte für ihn 250.000 euro möbel
erklärte inzwischen seinen austritt aus
der unionsfraktion
doch im bundestag will er erstmal noch
bleiben bis august denn das bringt ihm
noch mehr als 50.000 euro an die er
ergebnis der vertrauensverlust in die
politik wächst weiter mit der aktuellen
corona politik ist inzwischen jeder
zweite deutsche unzufrieden
ja hat mir gerade gesagt sie sind wütend
aber was werden sie jetzt persönlich
unternehmen dass jemand wie nikolas
löbel nicht noch einen weiteren tag ins
parlament zurück kommt auch georg
nüßlein hat angekündigt zwar aus ihrer
fraktion rauszugehen aber er will ins
zurück ins parlament geht es darum noch
mal weiter zu verdienen noch ein
bisschen pension abzukassieren was
werden sie tun wenn sie die beiden das
nächste mal sehen
also worum es ihm geht müssen sie die
beiden fragen
ich kann ihnen sagen wir haben sofort
uns dazu geäußert wir haben ganz klar
gesagt so ein verhalten ist unanständig
und es beschämt uns und wenn man so die
hand aufgehalten hat dann muss man sein
mandat niederlegen armin laschet ist
heute noch mal in aller deutlichkeit
gesagt ich hab's als cdu-generalsekretär
entsprechend kommentiert und ich weiss
ich spreche hier für die ganze partei
beide müssen jetzt den schritt gehen das
mandat niederlegen nicht nur aus der
bundestagsfraktion austreten und das
haben wir in aller deutlichkeit gesagt
also sie sagen sofort austreten und
nicht noch bis august weiter machen
natürlich jetzt sofort die menschen
verstehen es nicht man muss für seine
fehler einstehen und deswegen heißt es
jetzt das amt niederlegen legen das
mandat zurückgeben
er klingt bei wenn sie sich diese fälle
in der union anschauen die da
hochgekommen sind in den vergangenen
tagen können sie eigentlich ausschließen
dass bei auch bei ihnen so was hoch
bleibt in der spd gehe davon aus dass so
was bei uns nichts passiert dass es für
uns keine abgeordneten gibt die sich in
einer persönlichen notsituationen der in
diesem land sind persönlich bereichern
also da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher das
kann ich ausschließen für die
spd-fraktion kenne viele kolleginnen und
kollegen das geht in anderen politikern
er sicherlich genauso die tagtäglich
wirklich im einsatz sind die nicht
bemühen um die wahlkreise aber niemand
von denen käme auch nur im geringsten
auf die idee sich persönlich zu
bereichern
und man muss wirklich sagen das was da
jetzt in unions kollegen passiert ist
das schadet dem vertrauen in politik
insgesamt geschadet dem
abgeordnetenmandat deswegen ist völlig
richtig dass beide jetzt sofort ihre
mandate niederlegen müssen aber ich sage
auch ganz klar die müssen diese eine
million zurück bezahlen
diese persönliche bereicherung das ist
in die eigene tasche geflossen
dieses geld muss zurück da erwarte ich
auch dass solche summen jetzt
zurückgezahlt werden
sie sagen sie können das ausschließen
dass keiner in der spd-fraktion solche
deals abgeschlossen hat haben sie das
überprüft oder haben sie jetzt mal ihre
abgeordneten angerufen und gesagt wer da
irgendwas verdient hat jetzt alles auf
den tisch wenn es fast nicht zu meinem
selbstverständnis als abgeordnete noch
mal jeder von uns hat doch innen aber es
geht ja nicht um sie jetzt sondern es
geht ja um die gesamte spd-fraktion
weshalb ich gefragt habe kann nicht
ausschließen dass es in der spd-fraktion
vorkommen er warnte aber ich habe keine
hinweise darauf ich vertraue auch den
leuten in meiner fraktion ich gehe nicht
davon aus dass es ein solches verhalten
den weihnachts fraktionen gibt das ist
schäbig was da passiert ist das muss
korrigiert werden
es ist richtig dass bei die unions
fraktion verlassen und jetzt muss das
geld auch zurückgezahlt werden der
kellner wenn sie auf die union blicken
in diesen tagen erstaunlicherweise hört
man von der grünen-spitze bislang nicht
so wirklich harte kritik auch an der
union liegt das daran
dass sie schon an die koalition denken
überhaupt nicht also wir haben seit
einer woche hart kritisiert und
vorschläge macht ich will noch mal sagen
wir haben hier erlebt geschäfte mit der
note einer nation das ist ungeheuerlich
und ja sie sollten sofort zurücktreten
und das geld zurückzahlen und es sind
eben leider mit sieben ja gesagt keine
einzelfälle wir haben zwei weitere fälle
von abgeordneten die kleinen geschäfte
für aserbaidschan gemacht haben ist es
gerade philipp am tor
letztes jahr im zentrum eines skandals
stand in mecklenburg vorpommern zum
spitzenkandidat für die bundestagswahl
erneut jetzt am wochenende gewährte man
kann sagen gegen korruption wurde noch
kein impfstoff entwickelt doch würde ich
das sonst der unionsfraktion wirklich
empfehlen
und wir haben ja schon anfang der woche
haben wir vorschläge macht
und da würde mich freuen wenn sie mir
gesagt ja lasst uns den weg gehen wir
haben doch die union blockiert seit
jahren seit jahren blockiert sie
vorschläge für bessere kontrolle und
transparenz in der politik
wir haben montag noch mal vorgeschlagen
ein lobbyregister dass der vorschlag der
großen koalition ist kritisiert kommen
vom bdi familienunternehmern naro
transparency international den ist das
viel zu wenig lassen sie uns
nebentätigkeiten von abgeordneten auf
heller und cent veröffentlichen
lassen sie uns karenzzeiten einführen
für regierungsmitglieder oder lassen sie
die parteienfinanzierung verändern so
dass spenden die offenlegungspflicht
viel früher greift das alles werden
vorschläge für eine offene und
transparente politik und die stellen wir
zur abstimmung ich würde mich freuen
wenn die union dafür den weg frei macht
die grünen fordern auf heller und cent
nebentätigkeiten angeben möglicherweise
auch spenden es gab ja jetzt einige
fälle bei ihnen eben herr nüßlein den
haben wir angesprochen löbel haben sie
endlich sorge dass da noch weiteres auf
blockt in den nächsten tagen und was tun
sie persönlich dafür jetzt dass die
beiden um wo es um horrende summen geht
dieses geldspenden zurückzahlen oder in
irgendeiner form sagen okay das war ein
fehler wir geben dieses geld zurück
indem wir das ja offen diskutieren und
deswegen stelle ich mich auch dieser
debatte hier und ich habe damals auch
schon als es um das logic ist dagegen
gesagt ja es ist ganz wichtig dass
transparenz herrscht und man weiß welche
art welche lobby gruppen wie arbeiten
welchen zutritt sie auch zum parlament
haben wer ist das eigentlich und wie
viel setzen sie dort ein
und deswegen bin ich da nicht nur
persönlich sondern die unionsfraktion ja
auch mit der spd jetzt auf einem guten
weg das zu tun und auch wenn es darum
geht was ist mit den nebentätigkeiten
und was ist auch mit spenden darüber
kann man diskutieren absolut was ist mit
zurück und zahlen und spenden der sohn
sie da von mir was ist mit den es so
noch was ist mit einer summe her
ziemlich finder als 660.000 euro in höhe
von 120.000 euro was ich mit den summen
was ist mit den summen um die es da
jetzt geht nüßlein und löbel was tun sie
persönlich dass die beiden das
geldspenden zurückzahlen
ich kann ihnen ja sagen wir sind jetzt
gerade dabei es war das wichtigste zu
klären nämlich dass die mandate
zurückgegeben werden das ist das was die
menschen beschäftigt warum sind sie noch
mitglieder des deutschen bundestag die
menschen beschäftigt auch entschuldigen
sie hat sie mir die menschen
beschäftigen auch da sind sich die
männer dass sich die politik so retten
bereichert haben uns aber ich muss mich
ich muss mich hier zumindest an die
regie wenden weil es sehr leise ist und
ich sie sehr schlecht verstehe wenn sie
mir dazwischenreden es ist zu leise wenn
sie es eigentlich will sie erziehung
merkt dann gebe ich die frage kurz
einmal weiter währenddessen bevor wir
zurückgehen und zwar in dem fall an den
fdp general volker wissing
herr wissing jetzt sind fdp-abgeordnete
durchaus dafür bekannt dass einige von
ihnen nebenjobs haben das ist da leute
gibt die dazu verdienen haben sie schon
mal nachgefragt wer bei ihnen somit
verdient hat im massengeschäft im im
geschäft was schnelltest angeht
die kolleginnen und kollegen der
bundestagsfraktion machen ihre
nebentätigkeiten dieser im rahmen ihrer
beruflichen tätigkeit ausüben ja
transparent und legen das entsprechend
der regeln des deutschen bundestages
offen das was wir hier bei der cdu csu
fraktion sehen
ist ja ein ungeheuerlicher vorgang da
hat man offensichtlich in der zeit in
der die nation in einer note sich
befindet zuerst mal an seine eigenen
profit gedacht das ist zutiefst
verwerflich und ich halte das für
absolut erforderlich dass die
abgeordneten ihre mandate niederlegen
dann aber er wir sind jetzt haben sie
keine der wagen zuerst als ich meine
frage nicht beantwortet meine werte
haben sie sorge dass das auch die fdp
betreffen wird wie gesagt in ihrer
partei gibt es viele die
nebentätigkeiten haben die auch gmbhs
haben glauben sie dass bei ihnen noch
was hoch bleibt nein ich habe diese
sorge nicht und auch keinerlei
anhaltspunkte dafür
und das ist ja nicht vergleichbar ob
jemand eine nebentätigkeit hat oder ob
er in einer solchen situation wo die
nation in not ist und diese masken
braucht sich überlegt wie er daraus für
sich persönlich und privat ein
geschäftsmodell machen kann
und offensichtlich sind es ja keine
einzelfälle sonst hätten sich ja nicht
die fraktionsvorsitzenden schriftlich an
die abgeordneten gewandt
das heißt sie fordern einen
untersuchungsausschuss jetzt um das
ganze auf zu planen nein ich fordere
dass diese dinge aufgearbeitet werden
auf wochenend und drauf und csu fraktion
schlimm weil zunächst einmal die justiz
die sachen aufarbeiten muss es sind ja
ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet und
dann werden diese liegende juristisch
aufgearbeitet als nächstes müssen wir so
schnell wie möglich natürlich
konsequenzen haben damit das vertrauen
in die politik nicht nachhaltig gestört
wird das volk möchte dass die
abgeordneten die interessen des volkes
vertreten und nicht in ihre eigene
tasche wirtschaften und dann muss
natürlich auch geprüft werden was kann
so schnell wie möglich auf den weg
gebracht werden um die offensichtlichen
transparenz lücken des deutschen
bundestages aber draußen war
beispielsweise indem man ein
lobbyregister schafft warum vermuten sie
weitere fälle wissen haben sie da
anhaltspunkte
nein ich vermute das ist jedenfalls
seitens der fraktionsvorsitzenden von
cdu csu und eine sorge gibt es ansonsten
hätten sie sich ja nicht an alle
abgeordneten mit einem
schreiben gewandt und auf die
notwendigkeit hingewiesen in einer
solchen situation nicht an die eigene
tasche zu denken sondern an die
interessen der bevölkerung dieser briefe
hat mich etwas verwundert weil das
normalerweise ja selbstverständlich sein
sollte dass abgeordnete in einer so
schwierigen situation wenn sie etwas
vermitteln können an masken nicht daran
denken geld zu verdienen sondern daran
denken die dinge so schnell wie möglich
an die bedürftigen zu bringen
insofern ich habe keinen konkreten
verdacht nein aber mich erstaunt dieser
brief an alle abgeordneten
denn offensichtlich halten hält man
einen solchen brief ja seitens der
fraktionsführung der cdu csu fraktion
für erforderlich und jetzt müssen diese
dinge aufgeklärt werden das muss
transparenz geschaffen werden für die
gesamte politik ist da ein schwerer
schaden entstanden
wir geben die frage weiter an paul
sieben jahren den cdu-general er
ziemlich sie sprechen mit ihren leuten
wahrscheinlich tag und nacht um
herauszufinden was es da noch weitere es
gibt was da noch kommen kann und was die
union ja auch massiv weiter schädigen
kann was wissen sie und was können sie
uns erzählen was da in ihrer partei in
der fraktion in den nächsten tagen noch
explodiert also ralph brinkhaus und
alexander dobrindt haben einen klaren
und unmissverständlichen brief an alle
abgeordneten geschrieben in dem klar
wurde
sowas wird nicht toleriert so was passt
auch nicht zu den moralischen ansprüchen
der cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion so was
passt nicht zu den moralischen auch
ansprüchen von cdu und csu also beider
parteien es gibt da eine null toleranz
sie sagen null toleranz aber es gibt ja
nicht nur eine partei und führung der
fraktion und deswegen vertraue ich
genauso wie lars klingbeil das tut auf
bei seiner fraktion dass jedem klar ist
dass so etwas nicht geht also sind sie
jetzt sichert dass da nichts mehr kommt
selbst die mensch diejenigen die dort
irgendwo beteiligt gewesen wäre sind sie
jetzt sicher sind sie sicher dass da
jetzt nichts mehr kommt bei ihnen können
sie da sagen wir haben alle gefragt noch
weitere skandale gibt es nicht
ich gehe davon aus dass jeder
abgeordnete die gleichen ansprüche an
sich stellt wie menschen das von uns
erwarten wir sind volksvertreter und wir
helfen auch in der krise wir vermitteln
kontakte aber halten nicht die hand auf
für die eigene tasche aber sind sie von
jedem sind sie sicher jedem auch hin und
weg sind sie sicher dass nicht noch
weitere abgeordnete die hand aufgehalten
haben also bisher ist es ja so dass wir
diese beiden fälle haben und es gibt
diese klare ansage des
fraktionsvorsitzenden des
landesgruppenchefs der csu und insofern
vertraue ich darauf dass alle sich
korrekt verhalten haben also das heißt
sie sind nicht sicher woher wissen sie
ich bin generalsekretär der cdu und ich
vertraue darauf dass alle abgeordneten
sich an die ansprüche halten die wir uns
alle selbst stellen das ist doch logisch
das ist doch in meiner situation genau
das gleiche wie in der in der situation
alle anderen generalsekretäre die heute
hier zugeschaltet sie sprechen über
vertrauen in der politik der kellner hat
sozusagen schon angeteasert das während
die gesamte cdu die gesamte union über
korruptionsfälle über nebentätigkeit
gesprochen hat ein mann nominiert wurde
am wochenende der im vergangenen jahr
massiv in der kritik stand mit
nebentätigkeiten nämlich philipp am tor
er hat neben geschäfte gemacht mit
augustus intelligence und ausgerechnet
am gestrigen tag wurde er auf platz eins
der landesliste in mecklenburg
vorpommern dominiert das ist der platz
wo vorher die kanzlerin war herr
klingbeil was ist das für ein zeichen
was die cdu da setzt
ein ganz schlechtes und ein zeichnung
das komplett gegen die wie ich finde
richtigen unter ehrbaren worte von
meinem kollegen paul signac läuft da
muss man sich schon fragen welches
zeichen wird der gesetzt also jemand der
vor kurzer zeit auch noch den
korruptionsskandal um sich herum hatte
der auf nachweisbar auskosten von firmen
unterwegs waren teuren hotels war der
auf seinem briefkopf des deutschen
bundestages werbung gemacht für ein
unternehmen das mag vielleicht alles
nicht strafbar gewesen sein aber das ist
alles sehr sehr unmoralisch was da
passiert ist und das zeichen das in
diesen tagen in dieser situation für die
union entsteht wenn eine solche person
direkter nachfolger von angela merkel an
der spitze der landesliste in
mecklenburg-vorpommern war ich glaube
das schadet auch der politik und das
muss die union erklären warum man einen
solchen weg geht erzielen wir können sie
uns das erklären oder wurden sie auch
überrascht davon dass plötzlich der
philipp am tor auf platz eins nominiert
wurde jetzt vermischen sie fälle die
miteinander nichts zu tun haben nämlich
die fälle das aufhalten der eigenen hand
in dieser not krise als es um
schutzgüter ging und die fehler die
philipp anderer gemacht hat und philipp
amt hat sofort eingeräumt es war ein
fehler
es war mindestens ein moralischer fehler
die generalstaatsanwaltschaft hat diesen
fall geprüft und ist zu der auffassung
gekommen dass nicht einmal ein
anfangsverdacht besteht die
bundestagsverwaltung hat den fall
eingehend geprüft hat sich alle
unterlagen zeigen dass uns zu dem
schluss gekommen
am tour ist kein vorwurf zu machen
trotzdem wie ich finde zu recht hat er
gesagt es war ein fehler weil schon
alleine dieser eindruck entstanden ist
er hat auf den vorsitz der landesvorsitz
der cdu mecklenburg vorpommern
verzichtet er bereute es glaube ich am
meisten das aber er hat gegen an schnell
wieder sein werk autorin der union hat
eine zweite chance verdient sie sagen
eine zweite chance verdient ich möchte
ihnen einmal zeigen was der spiegel
-reporter kollege der das ganze mit
aufgedeckt hat heute getwittert hat uns
war
formuliert der am tor hat nicht
öffentlich beantwortet wann genau er die
aktienoptionen bekam unklar blieb auch
wer die reisen bezahlt und wie teuer
diese waren der sonst so beredte
parlamentarier hat die affäre
ausgesessen und wird dafür jetzt von
seiner partei belohnt so scheint es herr
keller sie haben es gerade schon
angesprochen philipp am tor
wie sehen sie diesen fall und wenn da
nicht weiter aufgeklärt wird hat das
auch konsequenzen für eine mögliche
koalition mit der union nach der
bundestagswahl
nun wir haben jetzt am wochenende zwei
landtagswahlen und ich finde es in
beiden landtagswahlen können die
wählerinnen und wähler eine antwort
geben und ich habe das gefühl in beiden
ländern bis die union schlagbar und ich
finde das ist auch die richtige antwort
offensichtlich ist die union zu lange an
der macht sonst sie sich das sind
einfach zu viele einzelfälle und wir
sehen ja auch in der geschichte der
union immer wieder die schwarzen kasse
von helmut kohl mag ich hier einmal
daran erinnern und diese punkte zeigt ja
offensichtlich das ist ein kulturelles
haltungs problem zu der frage von
korruption gerät und deswegen ist es
nicht nur gut wenn sie merkt dass vor
ort halten noch besser wäre wenn wir ins
handeln kommen und wenn wir die
entsprechenden gesetzlichen regelungen
im deutschen bundestag verabschieden die
eine höhere transparenz erzielen
herzlich die frage an sie warum machen
sie nicht einfach was warum sagen sie
nicht ja wir müssen das hertha begrenzen
ich meine es ist erst vor wenigen tagen
oder vor einer woche raus gekommen dass
ihr minister jens spahn 9.999 euro
sozusagen aufgefordert hat das
unternehmer diese spenden vor einem
dinner finden sie es eigentlich okay
wenn da solche summen wo klar ist dass
das ganze erst ab 10.000 euro angegeben
werden muss finden sie nicht dass es
dafür klare linien geben muss einfach
nebentätigkeiten ganz klar
aufgezählt also mir ist nicht bekannt
dass ihren spaß irgendwo ihn
aufgefordert hat 9.999 euro zu spenden
das ist jetzt eine neue nein da wollen
sie nein nein er ziemlich falsch
verstanden
ja wir sind im zusammenhang mit dem
spenden dinner hat der gastgeber im
vorfeld nach unseren informationen dazu
aufgefordert diese 9000 999 euro zu
spenden zu spenden aber die spenden war
natürlich für den kreisverband in borken
ja es gibt eine regel also ab 10.000
euro wird veröffentlicht in welcher höhe
jemand an eine partei spendet egal an
welche gliederung bin ich es gewohnt
entscheidet immer derjenige der spendet
so ist die rechtslage und so erwarte ich
dass auch von jedem und den sachverhalt
vor ort ich war da nicht dabei ich kenne
auch nicht diese vorhaltungen die dort
gemacht werden aber der führen die
menschen sich doch komplett hinters
licht geführt oder wenn man sagt okay ab
10.000 muss man das angeben und einige
spenden da 9.999 euro um das eben nicht
anzugeben das zerstört doch gerade
dieses vertrauen in die politik hat sie
mir ja die also die höhe die der spenden
ab wann ein name veröffentlicht wird das
ist ja schon vor langer zeit geregelt
worden sagt ihnen ganz offen und sie
finden es cool relativ egal wie hoch
dieser höhe ist also sie werden auch
bereit das ganze abzusenken und zusagen
auch alle spenden unter 10.000 euro
sollten dann angegeben werden natürlich
können wir darüber sprechen es gibt ja
das ist ja eine eine zahl die festgelegt
wurde
herr wissing werden sie auch dafür dass
verändern kein naturgesetz ja das ist ja
spannend erzählt spricht sich dafür aus
spenden auch unter 10.000 euro zu
veröffentlichen werden sie auch dabei
wenn auf jeden fall dafür dass man das
auch überprüft ich halte diesen vorfall
auch für schwierig wenn man bei einem
spenden die der jäger 9.999 euro spendet
und das ganze ja offensichtlich genau
auf diese summe festgelegt wird um so
viel wie möglich so intransparent wie
wirklich zu spenden das ist nicht gut
und nach diesen vorfällen jetzt müssen
wir sowieso die regeln überprüfen so
kann man nicht weitermachen das sind
keine das ist ja nicht einfach sondern
das sind mehrere fälle und deswegen
bedarf es hier strengerer regeln das
muss schnell kommen
wir haben sonst einen ganz schnellen
vertrauensverlust die situation ist
finde ich sehr sehr ernst wir haben
jetzt eine situation dem volk geht es
nicht gut diese corona pandemie verlangt
den menschen enorm wichtig da wollen wir
da wollen wir dass ich habe gleich nach
aufzurufen ist das letzte da wollen wir
gleich darauf zurückkommen auf das
vertrauen aber ich möchte schnell um
hier eine entscheidung herbeizuführen so
zu sagen weil die richtigen fragen dass
man sich einig dass anzugehen da herr
klink sind sie auch dafür dass das
abgesenkt werden sollte wir sind da
sofort gesprächsbereit und muss auch
sagen naja gesprächsbereiter klima was
ist denn jetzt ihre positionen sind sie
dafür oder dagegen
er war bei uns stimmt man im
kreisvorstand schon über eine spende von
1000 euro ab ob man die annimmt oder
nicht insofern habe ich kein problem
damit wenn spenden früher veröffentlicht
werden wir haben dann nicht zu
verstecken das muss nachvollziehbar dass
muss transparent das muss für die
bevölkerung zugänglich sein also null
problem ich will aber noch mal betonen
wir haben jetzt endlich eine einigung
zum lobbyregister ja aber mich
interessiert gerade das thema erklingt
bei und deswegen würde ich gerne mal
alle da würde ich gerne mal jetzt alle
generalsekretäre die sich dafür
aussprechen dass die summe auch unter
10.000 euro veröffentlicht werden soll
einmal die hand heben bitte
das zugesagte einmal die an themen als
sehen
ich sehe auch ernennt ihn jagt und da
sich ein kellner und der klingbeil was
ist mit ihnen
ich habe die hand gehoben und sie haben
die hand gehoben also hiermit
beschlossen
bei bild die richtigen fragen meine
damen und herren das ist eigentlich eine
ein historischer schritt kann man sagen
die vier generalsekretäre der
wichtigsten parteien haben sich gerade
eben dafür ausgesprochen dass künftig
auch unter 10.000 euro
das ganze angegeben wird ich hoffe dass
sie dann auch vor der bundestagswahl
noch darüber sprechen wollen
aber ich muss noch eine frage an herrn
klink loswerden in dem zusammenhang wenn
wir jetzt über die summen sprechen die
da von hermann zimmer ich habe eine
bitte sie grün sehr und das geht
ziemlich ins ohr das ist interessant sie
mehr kann mich nicht gut verstehen
für sie bin ich zu laut dann mache ich
offenbar einiges richtig er klingt noch
eine frage an sie wenn es darum geht
über korruption zu sprechen über
nebentätigkeiten da gibt es ja jemand
bei ihnen der war mal bundeskanzler sie
waren auch mal büroleiter bei dem
gerhard schröder und der verdient sich
dumm und dämlich dadurch dass er für
einen kriegsverbrecher arbeitet und in
wahrheit muss man doch sagen das was da
die abgeordneten kassiert haben ist ja
peanuts im vergleich zu dem wie sich
gerhard schröder die taschen voll
gemacht habt wieso haben sie da
eigentlich kein stöhr gefühl wieso sagen
sie damals das geht eigentlich nicht
also punkt einzig sich war nicht
büroleiter von 2 ist herr schröder
arbeitet für gazprom ein internationales
konsortium und punkt 3 ist gerhard
schröder wurde als bundeskanzler
abgewählt er ist kein aktiver politiker
mehr
er hat selbst gesagt ich entscheide was
ich mache ich entscheide wo ich mein
geld verdiene
und das bis der unterschied zu den
kollegen die jetzt im parlament sitzen
die vom volk gewählt sind die mandate
haben und die in einer schweren pandemie
mobile gerade als politik versuchen
dieses land durch die schwere zeit zu
bringen wo diese kollegin sich
persönlich bereichert habe also das
nochmals noch mal um es richtig zu
verstehen es stimmt ich glaub sie waren
praktikant bei gerhard schröder das habe
ich jetzt durcheinander bekommen aber
dennoch sind sie eng mit ihm verbunden
nur damit ich es richtig verstehe wer
das dann in ordnung
von gerhard schröder in der schlimmsten
krise seit dem zweiten weltkrieg mit
masken und mit tests irgendwie geschäfte
macht weil er völlig neuen parlament er
würde das nicht tun weil er in einer
persönlichen krise sich niemals
bereichern würde aber mit dem
kriegsverbrecher ist okay da geld zu
verdienen also mit jemand der in syrien
krankenhäuser bombardiert und die
ukraine an greift also von dem geld
nehmen ist in ordnung wir uns ja immer
noch mal gerd schröder entscheidet heute
wieder geld verdient sie haben gefragt
wurde in einer schweren pandemie sich
persönlich bereichert das hatte mich
getan
praktikant war ich auch nicht ich habe
schlicht und einfach im büro gearbeitet
ein bisschen besser recherchieren würde
sicherlich vor so einem abendessen ein
bisschen besser recherchieren sagen sie
aber gleichzeitig geben sie dazu dass
sie für ein schröder gearbeitet haben
und es eine enge verbindung gibt und die
bestreiten sie an ich deswegen meine
frage haben sie mit ihm da mal über
dieses thema gesprochen habe ich und was
sagt er
das war ein gespräch unter freunden und
das hat hier in der öffentlichkeit
nichts zu suchen
der kellner frage an sie wie nehmen sie
das wahr denn zum thema nebentätigkeiten
gehören ja eben nicht nur die aktiven
politiker sondern ganz oft ist es so
dass am ende
politiker die früher große ämter hatten
bundeskanzler waren minister waren
lobbyisten werden wie nehmen sie das
wahr was jemand wie gerhard schröder
dann im anschluss gemacht hat ich hatte
am anfang vorgeschlagen dass es auch
karenzzeiten gibt für
regierungsmitglieder mindestens zwei
jahre
aber ich muss auch sagen dass nach zwei
jahren karenzzeit ich die tätigkeit
eines ex bundeskanzlers für gazprom
völlig unangemessen findet und ich finde
da halb gerhard schröder auch dem
ansehen von politik keinen keinen
gefallen getan und ich finde das hätte
erlassen sollen da als ex regierungschef
bei einem russischen konzern anzuheuern
auch das ist keine sternstunde also wir
nehmen mit aus dieser runde wo es um die
frage in der ersten runde dieser sendung
um die frage korruption und
nebentätigkeiten gibt die für die hier
versammelt waren die wehren sich jetzt
nach der sendung dann wahrscheinlich
direkt zusammen telefoniert zusammen
smsen und vor allem darüber sprechen wie
man das noch vor der bundestagswahl
durchpeitschen kann das dann
nebentätigkeiten auch unter 10.000 euro
angegeben werden also sie sehen liebe
zuschauer unsere sendung macht richtig
sinn und die frage ist was beim testen
sinn macht oder kein sinn macht denn da
gibt es heftige debatten um die frage
was mit schnelltests in deutschland
passiert und das ist ein nächster punkt
der dafür sorgt dass viele menschen in
den vergangenen wochen und monaten das
vertrauen in die politik verloren haben
wir möchten ihnen einmal zeigen was am
wochenende in den aldi märkten los war
deutschland will sich auf corona testen
doch es fehlt immer noch an tests was er
nicht rechtzeitig geschafft hat schaffen
nun sie discounter wie aldi gestern
erster verkaufstag für die neuen all die
selbsttests lange schlangen nach zwölf
minuten sind alle tests
oft die meisten deutschen gehen leer aus
und müssen weiter darauf warten dass die
regierung endlich dafür sorgt eigentlich
soll es nun für jeden schüler pro woche
einen test geben doch wie die tests
jetzt an die schulen kommen völlig
unklar
und trotzdem die politik schöpft
ausgerechnet auf die die die tests
bereitstellen mecklenburg-vorpommerns
ministerpräsidenten manuela schwesig
schimpft über all die wirft dem
discounter vor
die neuen selbsttests zitat zu
verramschen
ja
gilt das versprechen oder soll das
versprechen der bundesregierung gelten
pro woche einen schnelltest für alle
bürger gratis allerdings zwei tage nach
aldi hat sieben jahren wie kann das sein
und glauben sie eigentlich daran dass
das jetzt auch wirklich mal funktioniert
mit diesen selbst test- und schnelltest
also ist es so die bundesregierung hat
800 millionen tests gesichert in der
umsetzung sind die länder verantwortlich
und wir sehen jetzt dass diese tests
kommen und dass die übrigens auch beim
discounter sind zu bekommen sind zu
kaufen sind das war vorher auch so
angekündigt aber die ministerpräsidentin
schwierige stinksauer sagt es kann doch
nicht sein weil aldi und co die
selbsttests verramschen die sie erst
seit mitte märz geliefert bekommen
würden da hat sie recht oder wie sehen
sie diese kritik
wer das was gerade passiert auch von
frau schwesig und insbesondere auch von
frau dreyer das ist ja beschämend da
versucht man wahlkampf zu machen und man
versucht nach berlin zu zeigen um von
den eigenen verfehlungen abzulenken
die länder waren informiert die länder
waren eingebunden und wenn etwas mit
testen nicht funktioniert zb in
rheinland pfalz von frau dreyer dann ist
das ihr versäumnis und das versäumnis
ihrer landesregierung und hat mit berlin
relativ wenig zu tun
dagegen war nur wahlkampf aus ihrer
richtung warum sozusagen kritisieren sie
da ausschließlich die bundesregierung
warum kritisieren sie nicht auch mal
ihre spd geführten länder also erstmal
glaube ich nicht dass vor drei
eingebunden waren die twitter strategie
von herrn sparende er vollmundig
verkündet hat beim ersten jetzt geht's
los
freiheit für alle das hat die kanzlerin
dann wieder eingefangen zusammen mit
olaf scholz dann hat man sich in der tat
hingesetzt wie dann ist ja die nächste
blase geplatzt
von jens spahn er hat verkündet ich habe
hier 500 millionen test gesichert und
dann kam raus sie sind überhaupt nicht
bestellt das ist überhaupt nicht auf den
weg gebracht jetzt haben die ganzen
bundesländer eigenständig bestellt das
kommt teilweise aber erst mitte märz
und wenn man jetzt konkret über
rheinland-pfalz spricht dann muss man
sagen dass es eines der länder die am
besten vorbereitet sind mal 3
er hat mitte feuerwehr unter anderem
verabredung getroffen dort sind über
dreieinhalb tausend freiwillige die
morgen loslegen es sind 300 testzentren
die im ganzen land aufgebaut sind also
da haben die länder was gemacht aber es
sind zwei versprechen jens spahn wieder
vollmundig was er alles macht und am
ende sind es die länder die es selbst
organisieren müssen ich finde so kommen
wir nicht durch einen anderen mieter
gemeinsam lösen müssen das ist ein
großes problem dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister zum
wiederholten male hier seinen job nicht
machen und andere das für ihn ausbaden
müssen
herr wissing sie sind teil der
regierungen in rheinland-pfalz wer hat
da jetzt wirklich versagt
also zunächst einmal cdu csu und spd
regieren dieses land im bund und das
hilft ja keinen wenn die sich
gegenseitig vorwerfen wer daran schuld
ist dass keine tests da sind den
bürgerinnen und bürgern tests
vorzuenthalten einer solchen situationen
ist unfassbar
der test ist genauso wie die impfung ein
weg aus der pandemie aus dem lock down
raus und wir brauchen so schnell wie
möglich diese dinge wir müssen mangel
verwalten weil man zu wenig impfstoff
bestellt hat und ganz offensichtlich
auch seitens herrn sparen
die aufträge zu spät erteilt worden sind
und es zu bestellen er musste ja selber
und das ist ja der beleg dafür dass die
versäumnisse bei ihm liegen seine
zugesagt seine zusage für den ersten
märz zurück nehmen konnte sie selbst
nicht einhalten und was ihm fast den
boden ausschlägt ist dass er irgendwann
dann hinterher noch getwittert hat aber
wieso gar nicht warum man sich an ihn
wenden er fühle sich da gar nicht
zuständig ist hat er doch irgendwie hat
das eine nicht weitergehen er wisse dass
er da nicht getwittert sondern da
möchten wir ihnen einmal zeigen was
vorgefallen ist am vergangenen
donnerstag eine bild exklusiv geschichte
dazu
was jens sparen zu den selbst test
gesagt hat jens spahn ein minister unter
immer größerem druck nachdem im chaos
klappt es nun auch nicht mit den
schnelltests und der minister will sich
aus der verantwortung ziehen fühlt sich
plötzlich gar nicht mehr zuständig warum
soll ich jetzt hier beschaffen so fragte
es sparen hinter den kulissen bild liegt
exklusiv das gesprächsprotokoll vor von
einer sitzung sparens mit den chefs der
größten deutschen discounter und
supermarktketten
ich verstehe ehrlicherweise überhaupt
nicht warum ich mich als
gesundheitsminister mit der frage
beschäftigen muss so sparen zu den
handelsposten die bundesländer die
sollten sich kümmern forderte
gesundheitsminister
ich weiß sowieso nicht warum wir denen
immer die dinge regeln sollen ein
gesundheitsminister der erst ein test
versprechen abgibt und dann mit der
bereitstellung nichts mehr zu tun haben
will
hat sie mir sie kennen ihren sparen gut
wie kann ein gesundheitsminister sowas
sagen ich weiß gar nicht warum ich mich
darum kümmern sollte also wissen sie ich
verstehe jetzt herrn klingbeil ich
verstehe auch im bissinger in der
regierung von frau dreyer man will jetzt
natürlich ein bisschen ablenken und nach
berlin zeigen und glas kling meine frage
richtete sich nicht nach mittlere
klingbeil oder rassistisch weil sie
beantworten meine frage nicht hetzen mir
geht es darum ob man als
bundesgesundheitsminister sowas sagen
kann
herr uns einmal jetzt lassen sie mich
mal ganz in ruhe ausführen und die jetzt
ein bisschen mit fakten wirklich freuen
wenn sie dann noch mal eine frage
beantwortet ja aber das ist es immer für
uns beide besser wenn wir mit fakten
arbeiten und jens spahn hat nie
versprochen dass er allen ländern alles
aber er hat gesagt dass ich nicht weiß
warum man sich kümmern so haben die ich
nachkommen nicht nachkommen müssen und
deswegen ist das schlicht entspricht das
nicht den tatsachen aber sie ihr ziel
ich möchte noch einmal zeigen was
ersparen genau gesagt hat und ich würde
gerne wissen ob sie das in ordnung
finden dass ein
bundesgesundheitsminister so redet ich
verstehe ehrlicherweise überhaupt nicht
warum ich mich als
bundesgesundheitsminister mit der frage
beschäftigen muss redet man so als
gesundheitsminister hätten sie das auch
gemacht
wissen sie das war jetzt eine interne
schalte jens spahn hat jetzt sehr sehr
viel verantwortung und dass man dann ein
bisschen in einer internen schalte wenn
dann die sache raus gegeben werden an
die bild zeitung dann ist das schon
ärgerlich wenn man irgendwo vertraulich
sprechen kann
insofern sage ich ihnen er meint damit
die frage muss der bund alles regeln
davon gehe ich aus aber natürlich sind
wir in verantwortung der
bundesgesundheitsminister ganz besonders
aber das sollte nicht ablenken dass das
was zum beispiel rheinland pfalz
passiert dass dort tests jetzt besorgt
wurden wer klingbeil gesagt hat ja es
ist aufgabe der landesregierung sich
darum zu kümmern
in rheinland pfalz eine völlige
selbstverständlichkeit der papa warum
hat herr roßmann das
deutschland-geschäft wochen wenn das
alles die länder machen soll warum hat
er damals per twitter angekündigt da war
zwar es noch der erste mehr hat dann
funktioniert alles wissen sie diese
geschichte ist doch ausdiskutiert wir
haben die dinge ordentlich geregelt es
geht um die frage wann was von wem
vorbereitet wird und jetzt ist es der
achte märz und nicht der erste märz und
jetzt schauen wir nach vorne
ich finde es muss ich ihnen ganz ehrlich
sagen auch in dieser sendung hier dieses
permanente mit dem finger auf andere
zeigen um sich einen parteipolitischen
vorteil zu sichern jedes mittel recht
hauptsache die eigene partei profitiert
das ist hier bei der bewältigung der
korona krise keine parteipolitische
angelegenheit sondern es geht darum wie
geht
weiter wie können wir möglichst schnell
wieder öffnen unter berücksichtigung der
zahlen
und es geht um krisen management und am
ende ein krisenmanagement wo ihre platte
kolossal versagt hat sieben jahre wenn
wir die minister anschauen hier
entspannen
herr altmaier zum beispiel das ist doch
ein scheitern auf kompletter ebene sehen
sie herr wonsheimer schauen also sie
dürfen nicht nur bild zeitung lesen und
die bild app benutzen sondern sie müssen
sich auch ein bisschen anschauen wie die
situation auch in anderen ländern ist
wenn sie das gesamte krisenmanagement 10
sie können mir glauben ich lese auch
viele internationale gesagt unterstehe
die kritikpunkte
ich hätte als auch gerne stelle auch
beim testen auch beim impfen bei vielen
anderen dingen aber schauen sie sich mal
an wie wir durch die krise gekommen sind
ich finde dieses land hat toll
zusammengehalten und alle miteinander
das gilt übrigens auch für die spd die
das jetzt aus parteitaktischen gründen
wahlkampf gründen nicht so macht alle
auch in den ländern übrigens egal wie
die farbe der landesregierung ist alle
haben miteinander hart gearbeitet und
wir haben viel geschafft
herr keller wie nehmen sie die
performance des
bundesgesundheitsministers in diesen
tagen wochen monaten muss man ja schon
fast sagen war
nun es gibt mir ebenso schuld sind immer
die anderen
das hat paul signac zwar gerade sehr
sehr schön gesagt wirklich teil
man hat er gerade eine rede weiter zuvor
auf malu dreyer und manuela schwesig
gezeigt
und in der tat ich finde wenn wir uns
mal anschauen und ganz in ruhe anschauen
wie ist das denn mit dem schnelltest
also in österreich sind sie seit wochen
zugelassen und werden dort verwendet und
ist es nur die zulassung solcher test
nun wirklich nicht die bundesländer
zuständig sind das wird glaube ich in
dieser runde hier niemand behaupten und
das schnelltests zu einer sinnvollen
einführungsstrategie welt zu gehören
darüber reden wir seit ende letzten
jahres
und das ist nicht geregelt wurde und
dass das letzte woche ein arbeitskreis
gegründet wurde unter anführung von
andreas scheuer maut war sein hobby und
jens spahn während aldi am samstag die
dinger raus bringt das zeigt doch das
ganze armut zeugnis diese regierung bei
der frage der stellte herr klingbeil wie
haben sie das wahrgenommen was der
bundesgesundheitsminister dort gesagt
hat bei dem treffen mit den chefs der
drogeriemärkte
es passt leider ins bild ja das muss man
muss man sagen jens spahn ist seit seit
monaten gefordert er hat zwei große
aufgaben er hat die aufgabe das impfen
vorzubereiten dass es wahrscheinlich
sogar die wichtigere und wir alle wissen
seit monaten auch dass das testen mit zu
einer öffnung strategie dazu gehört und
beides nicht ausreichend vorbereitet und
ich möchte den pc-markt das schon hart
widersprechen es geht überhaupt nicht um
ein generelles schlecht reden oder es
geht nicht darum dass wir jetzt
irgendwie da permanent kritisieren aber
wir müssen doch die kraft haben auch die
fehler die passieren zu benennen immer
mit dem ziel übrigens dass wir besser
werden und dass wir vorankommen
beim image haben wir das getan und wir
sehen jetzt wir kommen in eine ganz
andere situation bei wir mehr
produktionskapazitäten aufgebaut wurden
weil mehr nachbestellt wurde also wir
werden jetzt ein paar wochen schon eine
situation haben dass wir sehr viele
impfdosen haben dafür müssen wir die
richtige infrastruktur aufbauen und beim
test sind noch mal wenn ihr einsparen
rausgeht bei twitter und wenn er
erwartung weckt und wenn er sagt dass
erster märz geht das für alle kostenlos
dann braucht er einen plan in der tasche
und den hat er nicht gehabt und auch das
zerstört vertrauen in politik und wir
haben jetzt viele monate davon
profitiert dass die menschen uns
vertraut haben dass sie diesen weg
mitgegangen bin sind und ich bin ganz
klar ich möchte nicht aufgrund der
fehlleistung eins seiner ministerinnen
minister aufgrund dieser krassen
fehlleistung ich habe keine lust dass
dadurch das generelle vertrauen in die
politik verloren geht und deswegen bin
ich sogar in der pflicht finde ich es
ist wirklich deutlich anzusprechen unter
den teppich kehren geht in einer solchen
situation nicht als sieben jahre
gefährdet jetzt sparen das vertrauen in
die politik insgesamt sowie lars
klingbeil kritisiert ach wissen sie das
war jetzt eine parteipolitische
ansprache in allerbester werbe man ihr
das braucht man doch jetzt nicht groß zu
kommentieren
trotzdem trifft finden wie sie das sehen
dass jetzt der impfung com ist doch ist
doch ist doch ganz wichtig und ein aber
mich interessiert wie sie den betrachter
sonntag eine solaranlage die
entschuldigung sagen braucht herr spahn
in diesen zeiten immer mehr zu einer
belastung wird
wir uns die werte auch der union an
schauen sie rauschen weiter nach unten
auch die beliebtheitswerte des ministers
genauso im übrigen von
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
das ist doch eine belastung für sie als
verteilen diesen zeiten sind jetzt
schwierige zeiten weil die lage im land
schwierig ist und es ist so wissen sie
viele sind zuständig aber ganz oben wenn
sie zum beispiel peter altmaier iren
sparen ansprechen andere tragen die
verantwortung dass die politischen gegen
das sich darauf ein schießen
die spd wäre lieber opposition dass die
opposition ist aber selbst auch das ist
ganz normal in einer demokratie
vielleicht nicht angemessen jetzt in
dieser krise und deswegen sage ich ich
schaue nicht auf umfragewerte
ich schaue auch nicht auf
beliebtheitswerte ich schaue darauf ist
es wichtig jetzt für dieses land wie
gehen die genießen öffnung schritte
weiter und wie ist unsere situation auch
im vergleich zu anderen europäischen
ländern darauf kommt es an und die
bewältigung der folgen der korona
pandemie mir geht es um die sache nicht
um parteipolitik sie sagen ihnen geht es
um die sache und nicht um die
parteipolitik gleichzeitig leben wir
wahlkämpfer von ihnen in
baden-württemberg und in rheinland-pfalz
die bereits offen kritisieren was die
regierung im bund macht wir haben da am
wochenende ein interview erlebt mit
herrn paul darauf der spitzenkandidat in
rheinland pfalz der cdu und er sagt die
bundesregierung hat zu schlecht
kommuniziert gibt dort hart ins gericht
und in wahrheit sagt er schon na ja die
wahl werde ich irgendwie verlieren aber
schuld war der bund schuld war die
bundespartei schuld waren die minister
wie haben sie dieses interview
wahrgenommen als sie mir also erstmal
sich dass christian baldauf ein super
wahlkampf macht und ganz ausgezeichnete
ideen hat auch für die zukunft des
landes und wenn sie über die frage der
kommunikation sprechen dann ist das
tatsächlich ein wichtiger punkt wie
kommunizieren wir welche erwartungen
weckt mann und ich glaube da können wir
jeden tag besser werden zu erklären was
ist gerade jetzt eigentlich wichtig wie
sehen die nächsten wochen aus wie sieht
die strategie aus kommunikation ist
etwas wo jeder gefordert ist die
minister wurden minister aber wir als
parlamentarier und auch alle parteien
davis irgendwie haben sie das
wahrgenommen dass
view in der bild am sonntag von volker
wissing vorhergesagt hat na ja in
wahrheit ist das problem in der bundes
partei wie erleben sie das glauben sie
hat schon aufgegeben
die cdu hatten sehr schwer entstand in
einem fall sei auch in baden württemberg
natürlich sind die verzögerungen bei der
impfstoff beschaffung dann die
ankündigung von tests die man vergessen
hat zu bestellen dann die nicht
fließenden wirtschaftshilfen durch peter
altmaier
in der summe ergibt sich ein desaströses
bild einer bundesregierung die in der
schwersten krise das land nicht im griff
hat und die mehr zuständigkeit
streitigkeiten mit den ländern führt
anstatt probleme zu lösen ich meine wenn
ich mir das an höre erst kündigt man an
tests für den ersten märz dann muss man
zugeben mal vergessen welche zu
bestellen dann erklärt man sei gar nicht
zuständig die länder sollen sich drum
kümmern und dann richtet man eine task
force an die eine test strategie
entwickeln soll
was sollen wir denn von so was noch
halten hier werden entschuldigungen
präsentiert aber keine lösungen
wir stecken in einer pandemie wir haben
einen locker und die leute wollen daraus
die ministerpräsidenten treffen sich mit
der bundeskanzlerin alle paar wochen
beim anordnen von verschärfungen von
schließungen ist man sich einig und dann
hinterher führt man zuständigkeit
streitigkeiten in aller öffentlichkeit
über die frage wer testet und wo kommt
der impfstoff her also ich kann
verstehen dass die wahlkämpfer der union
verzweifelt in dieser situation dass das
kein rückenwind ist ist klar
und ich glaube inzwischen ist auch allen
in deutschland klar dass das so nicht
weitergehen kann
wir werden nicht gut regiert viele
dachten ja deutschland sein modernes
land mit einer hervorragenden verwaltung
und jetzt stellen alle fest das war nur
fassade
im hintergrund sind die minister im bund
überfordert und bringen eine
entschuldigung nach der anderen
widersprechen sich von einem tag auf den
anderen das ein unglaublicher zustand
und deswegen ist das schwierig für
diejenigen die das vor ort vertreten
müssen also ich möchte nicht in der haut
von handball dorf stecken oder von frau
eisenmann in baden württemberg das ist
klar erkennbar wie die union so
plötzlich schlagbar weil sie jetzt im
nebenverdienst sumpf ist und mehrere
minister eine schlechte schwierige
performance ab
von
nochmal meine motivation ist jetzt
gerade dass wir schnell durch diese
pandemie durchkommen ich möchte dass wir
da im sommer durch sind ich möchte dass
wir schneller werden und ich möchte dass
das testen so funktioniert dass wir
jetzt eine öffnung strategie reinkommen
wir alle haben doch haben doch ja die
nase voll von corona und wollen das ist
besser wird und die probleme der union
wehrt sich da wie die schuld jetzt gibt
das das ist mir egal das müssen die
unter sich klären ich möchte diese
korruptionsfälle geklärt werden dass die
mandate zurückgegeben werden dass das
geld zurückgegeben wird aber ich
beteilige ich mich nicht an der suche
nach schuldigen innerhalb der union aber
vor ein paar wochen war die und nun noch
unheilbar vorn und unter 0 vorn
ja und ja und wenn die frage zu baden
württemberg dann möchte ich das oder zu
rheinland-pfalz möchte ich das gerne
davon trennen
wir haben in rheinland pfalz ein
großartiger ministerpräsidentin mit
marie dreier da gibt es eine gut
funktionierende landesregierung und in
baden württemberg stürzen dass sie total
ab muss man dagegen sagen wir kämpfen
jetzt dafür dass diese landesregierung
mit malu dreyer an der spitze dass sie
weitermachen kann und in baden
württemberg kämpft die spd dafür in
diese regierung rein zu kommen und jetzt
haben wir noch eine woche
die geben gas da machen wir ordentlich
wahlkampf und dann bin ich mir sicher
wird das ein ordentlicher wahlsonntag
nächsten sonntag aber das möchte ich
wirklich völlig davon trennen dass wir
auf bundesebene probleme haben in der
korona pandemie die wir im sinne der
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
einfach jetzt schlichtweg lösen müssen
wir wollen das haben wir jetzt
verstandene klingbeil dass sie probleme
lösen wollen
kellner wenn sie sozusagen auf den
wahlkampf in baden württemberg schauen
und auch anderswo und wenn sie
gleichzeitig sehen dass die union so
applaus dass sie da nebenverdienst sumpf
liegt man weiß nicht so genau was kommt
noch hoch gleichzeitig verlieren die
menschen immer mehr das vertrauen in die
regierung machen sie sich da eigentlich
sorgen um ihren wunsch koalitionspartner
nach der bundestagswahl weil bei ihnen
träumen doch schon alle davon endlich in
die regierung einzutreten vielleicht und
eigentlich mit der union eine koalition
zu fahren
also wir wollen regieren und zwar wollen
wir regieren weil die dringlichkeit der
klimakrise es notwendig macht dass wir
endlich ins handeln kommen und ja dafür
möchte bündnis 90 grünen regieren
ehrlicherweise wenn sie mich fragen
würde was meine wunschkoalition wenn ich
es mir aussuchen könnte dann würde ich
sagen dann will ich mir eine grün rote
regierung wünschen
das wäre mein traum und mein wunsch aber
es geht bei dieser wahl ja nicht um
schwarz grün
es geht bei dieser nächsten
bundestagswahl um grün versus schwarz
grün rot sagt herr kerner hat sie mir
machen sich sorgen
wissen sie jetzt ist geht die diskussion
welche koalition was im wahlkampf ist
nochmal jetzt in der krise jetzt geht es
durch die krise zu kommen und dann
vernünftig darüber zu sprechen was ist
wichtig für deutschland und deswegen
werden wir dafür kämpfen dass die union
möglichst stark ist und ich freue mich
auf diesen wahlkampf wird eine
inhaltliche auseinandersetzung ist haben
sie schon wieder meine frage nicht
beantwortet 7er kellner sagt grün-rot
machen sich sorgen
ich wünsche mir eine möglichst schwarze
regierung absolute mehr aber sieht
momentan nicht danach aus
fragen sie mich dabei eine
wunschkonstellation also nochmal eine
möglichst starke union das ist wichtig
für dieses land und dann werden wir
schauen ich kann nur zwei sachen
ausschließen wir werden nicht mit der
linkspartei und nicht mit der afg
regierung erwägen wenn es um koalitionen
geht muss man sagen dass die fdp in den
vergangenen wochen angezogen hat sie
stehen in verschiedenen umfragen
zwischen sieben und zehn prozent wenn
jetzt ist darauf ankäme
bei der bundestagswahl sie haben die
möglichkeit in einer jamaika koalition
also mit cdu und grünen zugehen oder
eine ampel mit spd und grünen für was
für sich entscheiden das würden wir an
den inhalten festmachen
zunächst einmal würde derjenige auf uns
zukommen der den
regierungsbildungsauftrag bekommen hat
mit dem würden wir zuerst sprechen und
würden dann ausloten ob man zusammen
kommt für die fdp ist das eine
inhaltliche frage wir schielen nicht
nach anderen parteien wie erschien noch
nicht nach bestimmten aber noch einmal
solch peinlichen zu sagen aber
wahrscheinlich richtigen halt nochmal so
peinlich da ich werde natürlich
gesprächen rausgehen und sagen die
wollen wir nicht und dann so verprügelt
werden das wollen wir wahrscheinlich
auch nicht oder
dann der keiner will verprügelt werden
aber trotzdem muss man auch mal muss man
auch mal mutig sagen und auch mal nein
sagen wenn die inhalte nicht stimmen
wenn die union sich damals nicht
geweigert hatte den solidaritätszuschlag
abzubauen hätte man zusammenkommen
können das lag nicht an der fdp
wir haben uns ja nicht verbogen wir
haben uns auch nicht verweigert sondern
man hat uns nicht die hand gereicht aber
das sind es geschichte jetzt geht es
darum dass wir eine neue bundesländer
natürlich weitergehen ist mit armin
laschet zum beispiel alle verständlichen
sehe aber selbstverständlich aber es ist
selbstverständlich ist jamaika möglich
wir regieren in jamaika in schleswig
holstein regiert nach einem
schwarz-gelben bündnis in nordrhein
westfalen das sind beides hervorragende
regierungen aber die region mainz
funktioniert eben auch sehr gut und
deswegen ist es für die fdp eine frage
können wir beitrag leisten die
marktwirtschaft ein stück weit zu
erneuern in deutschland um die das land
auf wachstumskurs zu bringen und auch um
die rückstände aufzuarbeiten die
entstanden sind das ist selbst
entscheiden ich das richtig analysiert
genug dass wichtige richten sich sagen
dass ich nicht so richtig lust oder sehe
ich das falsch haben sie auf urlaub
scheitern sind ich so richtig lust oder
aber sie kennen das ich bin demokrat ich
finde dass die verantwortung am besten
bei christian linder aufgehoben ist ich
finde unser parteiprogramm das
überzeugendste war das ist nicht
wirklich überraschend wenn general vor
wir jetzt weiter natürlich sah es mit
einer feier eigentlich hin die wir nicht
richtig oder werden wir werden sie von
hand reichen um steuern zu erhöhen um
vermögenssteuern einzuführen er will
nicht über olaf scholz unterstützen um
steuern soll
bevor wir in die schlussrunde gehen
möchte ich doch noch einmal auf ein
thema kommen dass auch in diesen tagen
viele viele menschen beschäftigt neben
der frage was da bei den nebeneinkünften
passiert ist neben der frage ob das
jetzt mit den tests auch wirklich
funktioniert fragen sich viele wie geht
es in den nächsten wochen und monaten in
corona deutschland wirklich weiter und
sie mag wenn wir uns jetzt die inzidenz
zahlen anschauen dann machen sich viele
menschen sorgen dass diese öffnung von
denen sie gesprochen haben wie ihre
partei gesprochen hat am ende vielleicht
doch nicht kommen wie erleben sie das
ich erlebe das jetzt gerade in diesen
wochen in den letzten wochen natürlich
viele menschen weil wir schon so lange
diese einschränkungen haben müde sind
und gleichzeitig erlebe ich aber immer
noch ein großes verständnis dafür dass
diese maßnahmen notwendig sind also
beide gefühle sind ja richtig und
berechtigt einmal die müdigkeit und auf
der anderen seite das verständnis jetzt
haben wir einen fahrplan der die öffnung
schritte definiert wir schauen auf die
zahlen und sehen trotzdem es ist jetzt
mehr möglich und wir werden jetzt nach
diesem fahrplan weiter schauen und immer
wieder neu schauen müsste abzuwägen und
dann auch wieder neu zu beraten
und wie wütend macht dass die menschen
die sie auf der straße treffen das in
den usa schon als affen geimpft werden
und bei uns immer noch nicht mal die
über 80-jährigen zum großen teil geimpft
sind
er wollte den über 80-jährigen sind wir
ja im prinzip durch wir sehen übrigens
auch bei den anderen es gibt noch viele
dieser erwarten da kann ich ihnen viele
beispiele geben eine ziemlich da sind
wir noch nicht komplett durch
naja ich sage ja wir sind so gut wie
durch und wir sehen jetzt auch bei den
todeszahlen eben bei ihnen diesen alters
worden das ist etwas das ist sehr sehr
viel bringt wir werden es werden jetzt
auch die haus den hausärzten wird
ermöglicht werden zu impfen und das wird
dann organisiert über die apotheken wird
der impfstoff daneben ausgeliefert ich
würde mir wie jeder normale mensch in
deutschland wünschen dass wir mehr
impfstoff jetzt schon hätten uns schnell
hätten das ist ganz normal ist war klar
das ist am anfang wenig impfstoff geben
viel kollege marcus böhme der das im
general habe sie scharf hat die hat jens
spahn scharf kritisiert hat gesagt viel
zu wenig da beim impfstoff und auch
schlecht bei den selbsttest warum
prügelt der eigentlich so auf jeden
sparen ein und sie verteidigen ihn so
sind doch eigentlich eine funktion oder
wir sind eine fraktion und wg es geht
jetzt darum wie geht es weiter wir haben
jetzt beim im staat kleine zahlen gab
wir haben jetzt weit über 150.000
impfungen haben tag in tageshöchstwerten
und jetzt wird jetzt ansteigen und immer
mehr werden und deswegen ist das ziel ja
bis zum september jedem deutschen ein
impfangebot gemacht zu haben und
deswegen sehe ich mit großer sorge auf
die aktuellen zahlen habe aber trotzdem
hoffnung dass in dem verbindung
austesten mit einer mit mit einer
entsprechenden strategie bei schulen bei
kitas also testen impfen und dann auch
beispielsweise die kontakt nach
verfolgung mittels digitaler
möglichkeiten die es ja gibt dass das
zusammen dazu führen wird dass wir
unsere freiheiten wieder zurückbekommen
schritt für schritt vorsicht aber
gleichzeitig auch abwägung welche folgen
das haben kann
herr klingbeil wenn sie sehen bild hat
das getitelt am samstag der die affen
oder einige affen die in den usa schon
geimpft sind wie sehr macht sie das
wütend dass weder in deutschland immer
noch hinten dran sind und was bedeutet
dass dann am ende für konkrete öffnung
schritte
also erstmal bin ich froh dass wir bei
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sind da
haben wir auch viele von uns hat auch
ich druck gemacht dass es konkrete
nachvollziehbare kriterien es gibt ab
wann das passiert und das ist glaube ich
schon mal wichtig so und jetzt geht es
um drei dinge die er produziert gerade
angesprochen im kontext kontakte markt
verfolgen und das ist der job den wir in
der politik zu machen haben und unter
stört ist dann schon und ich gucke jetzt
gar nicht mal auf die affen und die
meldung aber wenn man sieht dass in
großbritannien jetzt gesagt wird im juni
können wir wieder komplett zurück ins
normale leben wenn wir die bilder aus
israel sehen wo jetzt schon viele geübt
sind und das mit doch dann noch mal
richtig hart wenn wir dann in ein paar
wochen sehen andere länder sind zurück
im normalen leben und wie hängen einfach
hinterher und deswegen eher wonsheimer
glaube ich wirklich dass jetzt noch mal
ein ruck durch dieses land gehen muss
dass es in der verantwortung auch von
jens spahn und anderen ist alle an einen
tisch zu holen
das für die impfzentren 24 stunden
sieben tage die woche ausland aber er
klingt weil sie sind ja teil der
regierung sie kritisieren dass ein
wochen und monaten und sagen die sollen
alle an einen tisch sie haben der
ministerpräsident die sie gut kennen
warum nehmen sie denn dann verdammt noch
mal nicht 24 stunden in den ländern wo
sie es könnten wo sie regieren das
versteht doch keiner
also wenn sie erfolg haben dann haben
wir jetzt gerade endlich einen
beauftragten in der regierung geschaffen
das ist ein enger vertrauter herzlich wo
die klassenlehrerin monaten sind sie
dann mal drauf gekommen beauftragten zu
benennen wir haben uns die kritik die
ich mir an wir haben uns zu lange darauf
verlassen dass der zuständige minister
das thema ägypten vorbereitet und am
ende war es dann die kanzlerin die
ermittler task force um das thema
weggenommen hat jetzt gesagt hat das
müssen andere machen
eine task force die sich jetzt um das
thema testen kümmert ja das ist zu spät
gekommen aber jetzt geht es darum nach
vorne zu gucken und das beste zu machen
und ich sage ihnen wenn man thw wenn man
die feuerwehren wenn man die bundeswehr
wenn man die anderen hilfsorganisationen
alle an einen tisch holt wenn man die
politik das gesagt hat die hausärzte die
apotheker die betriebsärzte mit einem
tisch holt dann werden wir schneller
fertig aber wir müssen wegkommen von
dieser unambitioniert hat die in manchen
ministerien da ist wie dann machen wir
als spd druck beim impfen brauchen wir
jetzt wirklich eine nationale
kraftanstrengung das testen gehört dazu
das kommt nichts sage ihnen ganz ehrlich
klingt kann
erding nationale kraftanstrengung nicht
mehr hören das höre ich seit monaten
auch von ihnen und von anderen herr
kellner wie erleben sie das
beim impfen in deutschland können sie
das noch hören wenn er wieder von
nationale kraftanstrengung die rede ist
und von einer taskforce und von einem
beauftragten und am ende werden in den
usa die affen geimpft und bei uns sind
die älteren nicht ran
ich höre einfach einen schneckentempo
und ich finde das einfach so wahnsinnig
diese corona pandemie zeigt auch ein
brennglas bei uns was schief läuft
wir kriegen das nicht organisiert es ist
langsam ist es zögerlich und dauert
alles viel zu lang
aber es ist ja nicht nur jetzt beim
impfen so sondern ich bin ja gerade
zugeschaltet aus der uckermark ich hoffe
die ganze zeit dass das netz hier hält
weil auch der breitbandausbau nicht
vorankommen weil wir nachsehen in den
letzten jahren wie es mit der
digitalisierung in unserem land bestellt
ist das auch das hat sich doch in dieser
corona pandemie mit macht für alle
gezeigt und ich finde dass wir da einen
eine solche andere politik brauchen die
vorsorge schafft die investiert in
infrastruktur
da muss ich doch dringend etwas ändern
das haben wir deutlich in den letzten
wochen und monaten gesehen
der kellner wird es dann bei der wahl
wenn frau berg kanzlerkandidatin ist was
glauben sie gegen wen wird sie antreten
die entscheidung für uns und bastian
quartal machen müssen wir aber einen
betrag nennen schreiben er 10 jahre wer
wird am ende dieses anstrengenden
wahljahres oder dieses anstrengenden auf
corona jahres bei ihnen an vorderster
front stehen haben sie die sehnsucht da
markus söder oder sehen sie da armin
laschet momentan vorne
ob wir werden das zu gegebener zeit
besprechen sie kennen die antwort
die beiden arbeiten gut zusammen und ich
bin froh dass wir beide haben und die
entscheidung über den kanzlerkandidaten
treffen wir dann auch zu gegebener zeit
wissen womit rechnen sie am ende wer
wird bei der union das rennen machen und
mit wem könnten sie besser in einer
theoretischen koalition mit armin
laschet mit olaf scholz mit annalena
baerbock mit robert habeck oder mit olaf
scholz was wäre daher verfrüht
erstmals kommen zunächst auf die inhalte
an aber ich habe nie ein geheimnis
daraus gemacht dass armin laschet mit
uns ja in nordrhein westfalen wo
zusammenarbeit mit immer mehr konkrete
regierungserfahrungen und er weiß auch
um den wert der freien demokraten und
ihrer politischen inhalte ich rechne
damit dass er der kanzlerkandidat der
union wird aber ich möchte da auch nicht
spekulieren das ist letztlich eine
entscheidung der union
wir haben unsere personalfragen als
freidemokraten früh und klar geklärt bei
uns weiß man wo man dran ist er
klingbeil was womit rechnen sie wer wird
gegen olaf scholz antreten bei den
anderen parteien rechnen sie mit
annalena baerbock robert habeck und oder
mit ja und mit armin laschet oder markus
söder das entscheiden die anderen
parteien ich will mich da nicht
einmischen müssen sie bei der union
haben laschet und söder jetzt mehrere
tage gebraucht um sich zum teil von
kuppen unionsabgeordneten zu häusern und
verso entscheidungsschwach ist da ist
ganz klar beide sind schlagbar und wir
wollen dass olaf scholz kanzler wird
sie sagen sie wollen dass olaf scholz
kanzler wird partie merck hat sich noch
nicht richtig
das kolleg wer antreten soll das gilt
genauso für den kellner unter witzigen
sagt ja am liebsten würden sie schon mit
armin laschet koalieren am ende dieser
ja man muss sagen historischen die
richtigen fragen sendungen denn meine
damen und herren sie waren heute live
dabei als neue parteispenden grenzen
beschlossen wurden und ich frage jetzt
noch einmal in die runde der
generalsekretäre wir werden das
natürlich nach halten was denn da
passiert werden sie sich jetzt hier nach
dieser runde noch mal zusammen schließen
wie sie das dann in ihren parteien auch
durchbringen herr ziercke klingbeil herr
wissing erkenne was konkret werden sie
jetzt in den nächsten stunden in den
nächsten tagen tun damit sie dieses
versprechen einlösen können herz im
markt beginnen wir vielleicht einfach
mal mit ihm
wir werden jetzt sowieso ja miteinander
sprechen auch in der vor allem in der
bundestagsfraktion in der partei aber
auch was ziehen wir für lehren jetzt aus
diesen beiden fällen und dabei wird
alles eine rolle spielen also vor der
wahl noch in den bundestag war der wahl
noch in den bundestag ist was wird das
was wir gerade beschlossen haben auch
sie haben die hand gehoben das ist live
aufgezeichnet gewesen netzwerk werden
sie das noch vor dem in dieser
legislaturperiode dann auch beschließen
den bundestag
aber wir stimmen im parlament ab und den
vorstandssitzungen nicht im bild
sendungen sie haben mir die hand gehabt
sie haben doch ist ja wir haben vorhin
darüber diskutiert das was ich vorhin
gesagt habe dabei bleibt es auch
ich will leben zu führen wir werden
jetzt natürlich darüber sprechen das
geht ja nicht nur um parteispenden es
geht um die frage von mehr transparenz
die frage was können wir beim compliance
tun
das sind alles dinge die uns in den
nächsten wochen sicherlich auch
beschäftigen er klingbeil können sie
unter den zuschauern versprechen dass
sie nach der sendung den park anrufen
oder andere in der cdu und sagen ja wir
haben gerade bei die richtigen fragen
beschlossen dass auch alles unter 10.000
euro angegeben werden soll
können sie uns versprechen dass sie da
eine telefonkonferenz organisieren
also ich kann sie beruhigen wir sitzen
er regelmäßig in der runde der
generalsekretäre zusammen mit wir haben
ja jenseits von solchen sendungen auch
eine gute arbeitsbasis auf den weg
gehen können und da werden wir das
sicherlich dann auch beim nächsten mal
das ist gar nicht mehr so lange hin vor
dem ende der legislaturperiode vorher
redet jeder in seinen parteien und dann
ist es in der tat so wie der kollege
zehn jahre das gesagt hat gesetze
beschließen wir im parlament da haben
wir auch mit den fraktionen zu reden und
nicht hier in irgendwelchen live sendung
aber dass die eltern älter sind nicht
irgendwelche live sendern klingt bei da
sind die richtigen fragen und deswegen
die richtige frage jetzt an volker
wissing wert transparenzpflichten will
habe ich ja hier gesagt und die aussage
gilt vielen dank herr wissen glauben sie
den beiden regierungsparteien dass sie
damit machen und sagen unter 10.000 wird
auch alles angegeben und vor allem ist
also sie haben ja auch die hand gehoben
das hat mich ein bisschen gewundert denn
sie haben ja viele die da mit
nebentätigkeiten durchaus engagiert sind
aber wie kriegen sie das in ihrer
fraktion durch was wir gerade
beschlossen haben
ich habe gesagt wir sind da bereit zu
und ging weiter zu recht gesagt wir
schalten uns regelmäßig zusammen als
generalsekretär und selbstverständlich
unterstützen wir eine solche initiative
der kellner sie aus der uckermark ich
hoffe sie hören uns noch wie werden sie
damit umgehen sie haben wir ein
lobbyregister auch gefordert wenn man
sich jetzt zusammen findet können sie
versprechen dass sie das vor dem ende
der legislaturperiode angehen
nun ist es eine abgestimmte position bei
uns zwischen parteien und fraktionen
sowohl die absenkung der
offenlegungspflichten die wir gesprochen
haben auch als auch die einkünfte die
nebeneinkünfte von abgeordneten auf
heller und pfennig veröffentlichen
karenzzeiten habe ich noch vorgeschlagen
ein wirksames lobbyregister also bringen
sie bringen sie die gesetzesvorlage dann
ein können sie das hier versprechen
damit wir sozusagen das abschließen
können und unsere zuschauer wissen da
passiert auch wirklich passt also meine
fraktion vertritt diese position seit
jahren und wird sie wieder im bundestag
einbringen und freut sich darauf wenn
man gemeinsam beschlossen bekommt na
klar
bild wird genau zu schauen wie dann auch
die hier vertretenen generalsekretäre
stimmen werden wenn es einen vorschlag
gibt und vor allem ob sie es schaffen
werden am ende da ihre partei zu
überzeugen zumindest hier wurde die hand
gehoben eine historische die richtigen
fragen sendung kann man am ende dieses
abends sagen herzlichen dank dass sie
sich den fragen gestellt haben
herzlichen dank dem irak dem
cdu-generalsekretär lars klingbeil spd
generalsekretär volker wissing fdp
generalsekretär michael kellner
herzlichen dank und jetzt vielleicht
nicht die den arm heben zur abstimmung
sondern noch einmal winken und damit
tschüss
das war die richtige frau
heute abend ich bedanke mich und gleich
geht es weiter mitten in der nacht mit
einem anderen thema an anderen sujet es
geht um das große interview
märgen und bild wird live berichten
herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen
herzlichen dank dass sie dabei waren und
nächsten sonntag geht es weiter
[Musik]